[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host definition and this
is the channel where we explain it so
you don't have to if you've been keeping
up to date with the videos then you'll
know i dropped an entire leaked plot
breakdown for episode six
and after watching the finale last night
the leaks have turned out to be true
so what exactly did they say well from
here on out it's full spoilers ahead so
if you're not fully caught up with
season 8 then i highly suggest that you
turn off now
but without the way i just want to give
a huge thank you for clicking this video
i hope you enjoy it now sit back relax
and let's get into my overall thoughts
on
season 8. okay so the leak said that the
episodes
opened on tyrion discovering jamie and
cersei beneath the rubble
and after this that he threw his hand of
the queen badge at danny in outrage
from here jon snow killed dany and
drogan burnt the throne
bran was appointed king and sansa still
got to rule westeros
and numerous numerous numerous things
that's just a quick summary but if you
go back and watch the video
it's about six minutes long you'll see
that it's beat for beat the entire
episode now
rather than making everyone call me bran
stark the three-eyed raven
king of the six kingdoms lord of the
leaks
i instead sat down with the feeling that
i've had since reading the spoilers last
week
that this is bad season 8 has been
getting worse and worse the longer it
went on
and this final episode feels like a huge
departure for pretty much every
character
daenerys has slowly become her father
who famously wanted to burn the city to
the ground which is why he placed those
explosive green barrels around it
and dany seems to have just blindly
followed in his footsteps
because apparently craziness runs in her
blood it just feels
off and to see her stabbed at the last
moment by jon because she's went off the
deep end
feels like d and d the showrunners
didn't really know what they were doing
with her or why the character was so
appealing in the first place
she is the true underdog and always has
been from the start
she rose through the ranks liberated
slaves
and now all of a sudden she's a tyrant
it just doesn't make sense and it seems
like this was only put in place so that
the writers could justify a reason for
john to kill her
i don't really have a problem with this
as a turn as if it was handled
properly it would have been good but it
was so last minute and it's no surprise
that fans of her are really disappointed
she'll forever be remembered as a
genocidal maniac which is a polar
opposite to what we've had for the last
eight seasons
and just looking back over this entire
season
i just want to kind of go through it
episode by episode and discuss my
problems with it overall
okay so episode one now this was very
slow
especially on a re-watch whilst it was
necessary
having all of the characters meet it did
sort of take its time which when you
look back at the restraints of the
season
this could have been a lot faster than
it was but
it isn't a bad episode it's very
methodical it has all of the characters
meeting for the first time
and without hindsight i'm guessing most
people enjoyed this
however there's one big thing that sort
of indicates that the series is a lot of
false promises and fake outs
and that comes at the end of the episode
we have jaime arrive at winterfell and
see none other than bran waiting for him
jaime of course pushed him out of a
window in the first season
paralyzed him and thus there's a lot of
bad blood between them
we then cut to credits fade to black and
as an audience we're all sat there
wondering what would happen for a week
then we get to the second episode and
there's nothing
it was a fake out used to keep us
interested and promising us things that
the show could not deliver on
bran is pretty much like long time no
see
and the rest of the episode feels like
it's just recapping what happened in
episode 1
without much development beyond it it's
all a waste of time
episode 3 comes along and it's supposed
to be the be be-all and end-all of the
entire show so far
but unless you've got your brightness
turned up to 100 you're not seeing much
now i've got a pretty good high-end tv
that's only about three months old
and even i had difficulty making it out
whether it was the copy i saw or
whatever
it seemed murky and thus the episode was
difficult to watch
however its biggest sin came at the end
when the night king was killed by arya
now i don't have a problem with her
doing this
i'm not someone who shouts mary sue at
every female character
she's definitely got the skills to do it
but the night king should not have died
in this way
this is a character we watched for
countless hours infest the world and
reanimate the dead
on his quest to get bran stalk he's been
unstoppable and many fans have theorized
that the connection between the two runs
far deeper than the villains simply
wanting to kill the character
turns out they were wrong though and the
night king has just been a force that
provided a couple of cool action scenes
and nothing more
cut to the next episode and you have yet
more poorly paced drama that feels far
too long at 90 minutes
cersei is painted out as the big bad
villain but beyond sipping red wine and
smirking she does very little
missandei is killed and after regal is
too it seems like king's landing aren't
going to be the pushover as everyone
thought
they proved just to be that though and
episode 5 is arguably the worst of the
bunch
where were the dragon killing weapons
where were the sharpshooters
and why did dany in victory decide to
become a mass murderer
it makes no sense and seeing cersei
killed by rox was a real gut punch for
all the wrong reasons
since the start i've wanted to see how
this villain goes out i mean
she's the biggest [ __ ] on tv and has
pretty much been an incredible foe to
watch throughout
so seeing her defeated by some bricks is
just
i just don't know where was the red
woman's prophecy that aria would kill
her
again promises promises promises
and thus we get to episode six whilst
game of thrones has always been about
not having a happy ending
i never thought it would be like this
nothing in this episode feels fulfilling
jon snow has been brought back to life
and why
so he can kill dany after being put in a
position that he never should have been
in the first place
it just doesn't make sense bran has
become the king but he never struck me
as a character that needed to be one
bran surely has the foresight to know
that in this world kings don't last long
are bound to become murderers and are
ultimately corrupted by their power
this is a boy who can control animals
travel through time
and see beyond what us mere mortals can
so why is he now bound to a position
where he'll spend the rest of his life
ruling there it makes little sense to me
personally
and i can see why so many people hate it
nowhere has this been prophesized
nowhere has this been hinted at and all
that building up
jon snow becoming a ruler has been cast
aside for a last minute shock
that feels completely undeserved there's
so much wrong with this season and it
feels like such a missed opportunity
no i won't be signing the petition to
remake it as it's never going to happen
but i will forever wonder what kind of
ending we could have had
had the creators not been so set on
rushing through everything in six
episodes
it's no wonder that so many of the
actors have come forth and voiced their
opinions of disappointment
as they were so much more invested in
the characters than we could ever be
it just feels like a massively missed
opportunity and
ask me again in 10 years if they made
the right decision but for now
yeah it's just bad obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts on the final season
of game of thrones so make sure you
comment below and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and make sure you check out my
breakdown on how i'd fix
season 8 which will be linked at the end
this is a channel for people who are
never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and i'll
see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you